PROFESSOR: Hello, and welcome
to a help session on
complementation.
Today, we are going
to be working
out a problem together.
If you have not yet had a chance
to work out the problem
on your own, please do so now,
and then return to this video.
All right, now that you've had
a chance to look at the
problem your on, let's
work it out together.
So, here we have a series of
different fruit flies.
They all have these recessive
mini-fly phenotypes.
So, we've noticed that
there are lots
of different mutations.
And, now, we would like
to put them into
complementation groups.
So, we start off by looking at
this nice, large Punnett
square we have, where all the
flies have been crossed to
each other.
So, if we look at A and B for
instance, when these two flies
are crossed together,
they still
have a mini-fly phenotype.
This means that the mutation is
in the same gene and that
these two mutants do not
complement each other, but
they make up one complementation
group.
So if we look farther down this
column, A and F together
also have a mini-fly
phenotype.
This means A, B, and F, all
three of these are in the same
complementation group.
So, now that we've already
looked at A and B, let's
continue on to C. So, C has a
normal fly in all of these
instances except this one.
When C and E are crossed
together, they also have a
mini-fly phenotype.
Thus, C and E also form a
complementation group.
So, now we're done with A,B, C,
E, and F. So looking at D,
D when crossed to all the other
flies, you never get a
mini-fly phenotype.
So, D must be in its own
complementation group.
Great, so we've identified all
three complementation groups.
So, moving on to the next
part of the problem.
We are asked, are mutations B
and C in the same gene, or are
they in different genes?
All right, so, if we look over
here at B and C together, when
these are crossed, we
get a normal fly.
This means that the mutations
were able to
complement each other.
Meaning that the two mutations
occur in different genes, and,
thus, when you cross the
flies, they're able to
compensate for each other.
So, they're in different
genes.
All right, now, in the last
part of the problem, we're
told that we are introduced to
a new fly, or a new mutant
fly, G. When G is crossed
to A, we get a
mini-fly phenotype out.
Also, when we cross G to B, we
also get a mini-fly phenotype.
So the question is, what
does this suggest to us
about mutant G?
Looking over here, we notice
that A and B are in the same
complementation group.
When A and B are crossed
together, we also get
mini-flies So, this suggests
to us that G is yet another
member of this complementation
group.
Thus, G also falls into
complementation
group number one.
This concludes our help problem
on complementation.
Thank you for joining us.